[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts headmaster albus
dumbledore
harry potter potion professor horace
slughorn and the events of the half
blood prince
i just re-watched the half-blood prince
for the 500th time last night
though it was not the most well received
of all of the films i really enjoyed
every time
particularly jim broadbent's performance
of slughorn and the unusual relationship
that he developed with harry potter
over the course of the film their
relationship though genuine in some
respects
was largely contrived the result of
dumbledore's instruction to harry
to become chosen by slughorn i tell you
all this
dumbledore continued not to turn you
against horus or
as we must now call him professor
slughorn but to put you on your guard
he will undoubtedly try to collect you
harry you would be the jewel of his
collection
the boy who lived or as they call you
these days the chosen one
basically dumbledore wanted harry to
become one of slughorn's absolute
favorites
he wanted him to the next member of
slughorn's slug club
but the truth is the dumbledore didn't
instruct harry to be chosen by slughorn
just to pad cyclone's shelf of
ex-students he didn't want harry to be
praised by psychon
just for the sake of it he had an agenda
dumbledore wanted one of sarcoin's
memories
and he was going to use harry to get it
after receiving his special mission from
dumbledore
harry's escapades begin he takes
dumbledore's mission very seriously
and kicks things off by enrolling in
saghorn's potions class so that he can
get closer to him
at the beginning dumbledore's
instructions are simple yet to know
sughhorn
but things begin to get a little bit
more complicated and a little more
serious
when dumbledore brings harry to his
office to look through the pensive
a pensive is a magical object used to
review memories
and while dumbledore eventually shows
harry a series of memories he starts
harry
off with one of his own at the moment
harry dips his head in the pencil's
water
he's suddenly taken all the way back to
the year 1938
as an observer the first thing to harry
witnesses is a very troubled looking boy
sitting alone in the room of an
orphanage walls orphanage
seconds later the boy gets a visitor and
that visitor turns out to be none other
than a young albus dumbledore after some
discussion
dumbledore reveals to the boy that a he
is a wizard
and b he is invited to hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry
what damondale did not know at that time
however was that this boy
tom riddle would go on to become the
most evil dark wizard
in history tom tormented the other
orphans and was supremely difficult
dumbledore even researched riddle and
became more familiar with his background
but it didn't mean that he was bad to
the core and it didn't mean that he
wouldn't get a chance
at hogwarts the point of this scene and
the point of dumbledore showing harry
all of this
was to give harry a sense of context for
the task that he would later give him
and the memories that he would later
show him he wanted to give harry an idea
of the troubled board that lord
voldemort once was
show him that tom riddle was once a
student much like him and show him how
his path of darkness began
the next memory that dumbledore shows
harry is one of slughorns
and it shows an older more refined more
together riddle
and in interaction with cyclone himself
slughorn was one of little's professors
you see in fact he was riddled's
favorite professor
in the memory riddle after praising the
slughorn with all sorts of compliments
and buttering him up with his favorite
pineapple treat asks
slughorn something i was in the library
the other night
in the restricted section and i read
something rather odd about a bit of rare
magic
is called as i understand it a
the next word that's uttered out of
phryl's mouth is muted the result of
saghorn tampering with his own memory
out of shame slughorn didn't stop there
either
as he made it seem as though he was
furious at riddle for even asking such a
question
telling him to leave at once this memory
was of course
almost entirely falsified and the real
memory that slughorn was trying to
conceal
revealed pivotal information regarding
voldemort and his horcruxes which
dumbledore had not yet confirmed riddle
had created
slughorn's real response went more like
this
i beg your pardon a horcrux i came
across the term while reading
and i didn't fully understand it i'm not
sure what you were reading tom
but this is very dark stuff very dark
indeed which is why i came to you
a horcrux is an object in which a person
is concealed part of their soul
but i don't understand how that works so
one splits one soul and hides part of it
in an object
by doing so you are protected should you
be attacked and your body destroyed
protected that part of your soul that is
hidden lives on
in other words you cannot die and how
does one split his soul
sir i think you already know the answer
to that tom
murder this is one of the most sinister
interactions from the entire harry
potter series
as it depicts like horn unknowingly
providing voldemort with the information
necessary to reach new
uncharted levels of power more than
anything however
it was important that dumbledore and
harry extract the real memory from
slughorn
as the fate of the wizarding world
depended on it for a good portion of the
book
film harry is trying to desperately win
psychonovo
so that you can learn the truth about
slughorn's memory but it's no easy task
and dumbledore makes it exceedingly
clear the fate of the wizarding world
potentially rests on harry's shoulders
my question is
why didn't dumbledore one of the most
talented wizards of all time
and just use another method to extract
suckhorn's memory
there are many ways of getting
information from someone in the
wizarding world
and though some of them are unethical
and illegal
surely the prevention of voldemort's
resurgence would have warranted such
courses of action
the first method the dumbledore could
have used would have been one of the
unforgivable curses
the imperious curse when the imperious
curse is cast on a victim
they are forced to perform the
unquestioned bidding of the caster they
adopt an extremely
carefree attitude and are inclined to
carry out tasks for the caster without
any sort of moral compass or
awareness of the caster's intentions or
desires
given that the root of slughorn hiding
his memory was shame
i think that this method would have been
more than suitable the next method that
i imagine he could have used would have
been
legitimacy legitimacy is essentially the
art of magically navigating through
someone's mind
it's very invasive and difficult to
perform but it allows you to see into
people's minds and read their thoughts
surely this would have been an option
for dumbledore who was one of the most
powerful wizards of all time
the next method that i imagine could
have been used would have been a potion
by the name
of veritas serum verita's serum is
basically a truth serum
which forces the consumer to answer
questions and reveal information
truthfully seems to me like that would
work perfectly in this situation
dumbledore was all about acting for the
greater good at least in his youth
and so i'm sure he would have been able
to justify such courses of action
particularly as the fate of the
wizarding world was resting on the
retrieval of this memory
so why didn't he pursue one of these
other courses of action
why put it all on harry we can rule out
use of the imperious curse almost
immediately
because dumbledore in his later years
was strongly opposed to the use of dark
magic
i think that the only way that dumb
would all resort to dark magic
like an unforgivable curse would be if
he had no other option
and he was confident that harry would be
able to get the job done
okay so no imperious curse but what
about veritas serum or legitimacy
they aren't exactly entirely innocent
causes of action but they certainly
aren't akin to an unforgivable curse
in the book's films harry actually
suggests one of these methods to
dumbledore
but surely sir he said keeping his voice
as respectful as possible you don't need
me
you could use legitimacy or veritas
serum professor slughorn is an extremely
able wizard who will be expecting both
said dumbledore he has much more
accomplished occlumency than poor wolf
in gaunt
and i would be astonished if he has not
carried an antidote to verita's serum
with him ever since i coerced him into
giving me this travesty of a
recollection
no i think it would be foolish to
attempt to rest the truth from professor
slughorn by force
and might do much more harm than good i
do not wish him to leave hogwarts
so there you have it damondal is opposed
to dark magic which meant that
imperial was never really an option for
him as for the other methods
well he didn't feel they would be
effective dumbledore also liked the
slughorn had returned to hogwarts
he was a powerful wizard and an
impressive potion professor
he was an asset to the school and it
would have been a regrettable decision
and that's it for this video did you
guys ever think about this
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]